tous ces appareils que vous voyez ici
les tous les 6 3 disques sont ici en ce
moment ont chacun une historique est
l'appareil le plus vieux 2 des 6 cts w
donc c'est le grand-père des adr bus
pour dix dans le monde avec le plus
d'heures qui le plus dense je pense que
tu te sens qu'ils mélangent 115 mille
heures de vol pour un avion livré en
1988 est acheté à air portugal
air transat en 2008 plus de trente ans
de bons et loyaux services pour un des
plus anciens modèles d'airbus
mais ce sont les appareils qui sont
entrés qui ont été très bien maintenue
qui pourrait même encore voler c'est
juste qu'avec qu'ils soient de la covec
naturellement transat a décidé de
retirer les trois derniers 3 10 de leur
flotte et des stationner ici
c'est à 310 seront remplacés par des
airbus a321 neo un peu plus petit mais
beaucoup plus économique mais ces avions
fin de vie ne sont pas morts ils vont
revivre en pièces détachées
l'avion arrive ici la première chose
qu'on fait c'est un bel et menteur passé
les deux composantes qui ont le plus de
valeur
le fpi ou en arrière le réserver par
lyonnais aussi le train d'atterrissage
ce sont toutes des pièces cure de grande
valeur donc c'est encore de la vie ce
sont les premières pièces que nous
allons enlever clés au préalable
l'appareil aura été purgée de son
carburant et de tous ces fluides ensuite
rené son équipe vont s'attaquer à
l'intérieur il y est venu avant jean
michel laviolette en état de vol
exactement l'avionique le câblage même
les connecteurs tout a de la valeur tous
les pièces qui sont ils vont être
enlevées et tout est vendable tous
esclaves sur le marché secondaire ya
énormément de pièces d'avion qui sont
utilisés aussi pour déjà qu'ils veulent
transformer certaines pièces comme les
sièges d'avion ils peuvent mettre des
roues en dessous une base et s'en
servait comme siège comme fauteuil
on a des panneaux qui sont décrits de
fenêtres de section que les gens veulent
utiliser comme des cas d'un côté
industriel chez eux donc énormément de
pièces qui étaient utilisés les ailes
les ailes d'avion beaucoup de gens les
airs on les utilise les découper fonds
l'étape de conférence avait donc et ils
font l'immobilier deux roues et un
armement de créativité au québec entre
man 10 les gens sont vraiment habitué
voilà aussi tout dernièrement on vire
avoir une demande d'un couple qui
veulent se marie à varna 3 is still
bientôt le cockpit ressemblera à ça donc
quand l'avion et on s'entraîne arrivants
voilà donc pourquoi procéder à des tests
sur tous les moteurs tout les systèmes
de l'avion l'état sans profondeur
et puis quand on a fini on vaut enlever
le carburant se passait chez les
réservoirs hydrauliques
le but c'est d'amener l'avion un degré
de pureté assez élevé pour que quand
qu'on va mettre la machinerie pour le
risque les bains l'aluminium qu'on a
envoyés au recyclart est le plus propre
possible
le découpage c'est la phase 4
spectaculaire on a un projet de
recherche avec l'école polytechnique ou
si maintenant que la semaine passée
l'école polytechnique a obtenu des fonds
du cng pour nous aider à développer de
la machinerie spécialisée donc qu'ils
vont nous aider à optimiser les coupes à
la phase 4 de découpage au lieu
d'utiliser un intense une ciseaux un
ciseau sur une pelle mécanique
ça va être une nouvelle façon qu'on l'a
déjà fait certains tests avec et des
dieux que des câbles pour découper les
cellules de m
oui la ligne homme est broyé ensuite été
envoyés à des fonderies qu'il heureux
c'est que l'aluminium il refait les
avions grecs
on va faire des avions et d'autres
pièces pas nécessairement juste les
pièces d'avion mais c'est le sli donc
c'est pour ça que pour nous on essaie
d'atteindre un taux de pourcentage de
plus élevé comme on n'est qu'à rome
dalil qu'on obtient un taux de 81 93 94
% tour d'un cela parce qu'ils seront au
total elle se compose i qui les
composent étaient certains matériaux
exact qui pose problème car on travaille
avec la ctec si au québec qui nous aide
à trouver des pistes d'un esclave pour
les composantes en ce moment les
composites
éventuellement on sait ce qu'on aimerait
atteindre 100 pour ça mais quand même
avec un taux d'efficacité de 94 % c'est
quand même bien l'opération prend une
journée bien remplie pour un gros
porteur jusqu'à de plus laissé une seule
trace sur le sol tout sera revendue on
vient de signer justement hier une
entente exclusive avec une scie à
l'aviation
donc nous en tant que héros cycle on
avait une personne qui est attitré à
leur revente des pièces une fois que les
pierres sont enlevés non seulement dans
la vente de leurs pièces de
d'avion des pièces de rechange mais
aussi dans le service qui a fait capable
d'aller le frère à nos compagnies
aériennes à travers le monde
non loin un des quatre a310 utilisé par
le premier ministre l'appareil que jean
chrétien dans l'opposition avait
fameusement baptisé le taj mahal volant
du premier ministre brian mulroney
l'appareil n'est plus tout jeune il a
besoin de pièces de rechange
à lire aussi qu est le seul recycleurs
d'avion au canada c'est une tâche
complexe il faut être homologué car
chaque pièce vendue doit l'être aussi
initial aviation entreprises québécoises
fait depuis 17 ans commerce de pièces
aéronautiques à travers le monde et
compte parmi les plus grandes compagnies
aériennes parmi ses clients dans ce cas
c'est serge et de st à l'arrière on note
arbus l'aco vite conduit l'industrie
aéronautique est un tournant
probablement historique
c'est du recyclage d'avions en fin de
vie il tiendra une grande place